I hear that you hear what someone
jumping around I was just so you know
yeah I know I know I'll get a hang at
the edge of the door so that you were
like in the night slip right by you
what's this what what's going on here
yeah I I may have messed this room up a
bit beforehand so that was really close
wave you actually almost had me yeah I
wait why it's why you got to be so bad
Wade so you got to be so bad you had
done that before
0:03 God - hang on no yeah crap no
wasn't bad it was just weird everything
was moving around you see the quarter
wait I leave you to your fate I have no
mercy for what the stupidity of what you
have Wow
those those by far the dumbest thing you
could do 20 so uh nineteen eight no I'm
olive you don't wait cuz he's a car
right that was your own dumb fault
wasn't it all that is the creep you know
I've ever seen mark ah thank you thank
you that is by far the scariest thing
I've ever seen
haha thank you I try oh my god I try so
hard
there's blood on that I try so hard
blood on him huh there's blood on me it
looks like it that's so mean
why does it mean cuz it's funny I can't
quite glitched look through the wearing
are you mark keep doing that yeah maybe
do you like God what there's a room full
of barrels is there
oh yeah the room full of barrels out all
of that where where where was it
I don't remember how to get to it it's
like upstairs by the entrance oh yeah
I'm not in there so you can rest assured
that we will not have dickery in there
this round oh yeah I remember
wait is this creepy it's very creepy I
don't understand what's door is
squeaking I'm coming for you eventually
mark you're gonna be right there shut up
he's not you know oh you ran out here I
saw you run out here yeah I'm out there
really yeah I mean oh I just gotta
listen for the door squeak and then I'll
know to head back to the door [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hiding that whole time the entire time
oh that sucks I kept going squeak you
didn't come by I am nowhere is that a
hint no I do exist okay
hi there is it down I'm having a really
hard time seeing what's going on but
that's not a very good hand either I did
just discover where the barrel room is
well I'm also moving around right now
are you are you a moving barrel because
I'm throwing barrels everywhere yeah I
just ran down the stairs behind you did
you because Wade's right there I don't
think that's true I think that's very
true I don't think he's in the barrel
room at all how do you know that he
could be you could just be waiting okay
I don't think he's in the barrel room so
Bob where uh where are you damn it Wow
it sucks when there's two people and you
stay together stay together you did you
were like 10 feet apart well I can't
help it he followed me Wade get out of
the door I'm trying shut up no no get
away get away get away
there's my idea what is it's my idea you
stay away no you stay away I wanted to
go upstairs and be a barrel I'm not bow
you son of a [ __ ] Bob I'm not up here
no matter what he said I'm not up here
you will never find me that backstabbing
bastard oh I'm so glad she good I'm glad
for you
Bob your destiny awaits you in the
barrel that sounded so ominous and
seductive I hope so I go for the death
awaits you
between my arm eyes what arms huh death
awaits you between my thighs no they
call it V Impaler oh yeah the Buffalo
scroungy horn the what I don't know what
I don't know that's not a thing is it
maybe I don't know is there such a thing
as like a buffalo with one horn and they
called like a you know you know lo o
woful Lorne oh oh oh
moving the barrows a well you'll never
guess which one is me well now you'll
never really work with shut up you'll
never know it's Baro is me hoo hee ha ha
ho ho see that ha ha ha
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry I had funder that would hey Bob
Bob I did it are you proud of me
no okay oh crap crap oh okay okay see
you coming through that doorway like a
[ __ ] I go loser oh oh oh we're playing
this game now I see you what was that
sound what's that sound I hear someone
using their crowbar like a loser
do you hear me shooting around like a
loser Bob where are you I uh I'm gonna
just commit to this I'm not gonna move
this entire time okay all right and I'm
something that's so unbelievably obvious
uh-huh like there's there's nothing you
could make mistake me for when you when
you find my spot it's not like I don't
know it's it's a horrible horrible spot
but I'm sticking with it really yeah
really
yes like a pearl in the barrel room I
doubt he's a barrel in the barrel
[Laughter]
those are an incredible spies never come
back we've never gone back there before
that was amazing thank you you're
welcome but it didn't work yeah if I
hadn't said anything you never order
came back outside no no I wouldn't have
I wouldn't I really wouldn't
I'll make out that as a win for me yes
in the heart of the of the people the
viewers you god damn it [ __ ] bag in the
mind of the people goddamn it [ __ ] bag I
have done goof real hard well Bob it
ain't gonna be hard this time I could
probably do that I can change between
two
things oh no wait I got it oh my good
ok I'm good man someone's messing with
my brain
[Music]
someone come back outside ah that's a
good strategy but goddamn it would you
do more try to run outside yeah tell me
it was outside I didn't think I had to
and wait how are you still alive
I don't know in all honesty thank you
wait are you actually one of these hey
what the hell you have been well the
last round
who will be victorious oh wait not wait
oh wait we're hunters oh my god no oh my
god yes oh my god yeah oh yeah man sorry
what happened Bob I fixed it
did you now that's too bad I did are you
in the barrel room wait I'll check the
barrel room
all right I think he's in the barrel
room I'm gonna go to the right you might
want to follow mark I think he's on to
me I think that mondo you're one of
these aren't you no oh yeah one of these
I know I know you are I know
oh you are where'd you go ah I know
you're in here ah I am so not you don't
know that and no others don't burst
q-bomb wait is he downstairs oh it's a
jug down
[Music]